おっとちょっと勘違いしないでくれあのお酒呑んべるの実はちゃんとデュガールれ
母のよくあるじゃないですか変な月シリーズ分かります絶対に買ってはいけないガチャ
とかすごい恐怖のがちゃんとかかったらすごい後悔するかざっとかあればそういう女
ためがわからないんですけどもう買わない方がいいですよみたいなのを掲げてみんなの
海太陽光
駆り立てるようなガチャ歳品目あると思うんですけども
買いたくなりますよねー
頭がぁそういう話をちゃんとなよねそういう話をしたいわけでない色ですよ
見たらこれみんなビックリすると思うんですけどはいこちらご購入は自己責任でお願い
します本当に買ってはいけないガチャ100 l を買ってはいけるんです
でまぁこれっぽい方は全然行くがあるじゃないってどこに行ってもってこれが違う
ところはね
見てみ対象年齢が15歳以上やばグルディスクなものでも入ってるんですかね今だけ
マニアックなものが入っている今まで以上の飾りが出まして当社編2倍このしたが
すごいと思ったんですよ
twitter のネタにしないでくださいそして注意ブログや youtube の
で
何もしないでください
やめねーバーバー皆さん安心してくださいこの動画ねお店の人に行こうかをとって道路
結果います
裏声でほど小沢見た時で絶対これ動画でしょうかなって来たんですね動画にしちゃダ
メっていうか寝たりしたらダメって書いてあるんですけどそういうのって買った人の
個人の徹さんあれじゃ購入した消費者の自由だと思うんですよ
ただで店内で撮ったりしたら話は別だと思うんですけど僕がついて店内動画いた時の話
で勝った方の中身でしょうかねだからこのみんなに見せて中にこういうのでしてって
紹介したいだけなどにそういうのが出たりしないのと同様に
でもそれやったね庁舎どうしてもそんな気に入ってなくても音はお店の権利もあるかな
といいんじゃないの
結局で互換機その女の人にで頼んでねこれ作動デザインですが大丈夫でしょうかといっ
たところ
お店の名前を出さないでえよっていう体だったお話も言ってもて降れ僕はそれを踏まえ
たうえで今動画で撮っておりがとうございましたあればだした
まあまとめると別に動画でしていいよということでした
具体的にどこで買ったとかお店のこととかを言わずに何か某所で買いました
どこで買ったかは言いませんがこういうガチャが
[音楽]
ブーバーしか入って
という中で普通に開けた後ちょっとこうなんかになっとっ
クサーっなると思うんですけどもなんか酔ったへ勢いだったらなんか許せるのかなと
思いましてこの状況だったら多分で何が出てもなんかこう広い心で許せるんじゃないか
なと思っていますと酒を売った日
4飲めねえ泳ぎでできガチャ神よまずはこちら
はい
なにこれ
ねボタンの機能のだねうんがはいいねぇいい
そこに数のかね
えっん
[音楽]
ブーバーすげーっ年前これいいんじゃない
ズルい俺だおおっとと白いですね楽しみなぁ
15才以上対象といって何を基準によってんだろうね
あっゴミクズがー俺物語だおおーー
うわ俺までどれ見てたにヴェーバーすぐ懐かしいなぁかわいい
俺物語の話ケースが増えてきました
ブラシはどこ
ああああああ
ほど北立あってからこその歯ブラシケースですからねそれだとただの
me
次来ません次はいっぱいなんだこれでカッコイイ
中田んでコレなにうぐぅシュートとラっぽいのでよくわかんないですけどこれ後ろ
カラー
後ろだったらなでは人だったら買ってくるのはここでね範囲
やばこれ工芸てビルらしいですやばいやばいお酒飲んでもうちょっとなんか
ってなっちゃいこちらどこれて気が付いてるアニメのキャラクターはなんかすごいあれ
ね可愛い男の部分写ってますあなたジルベールくんですありがとうございしたこれに
関しで本当に何も知りません是非はい
ちょちょ蔵置レバーはそのあれだ
ジョージだやったぁー
ああああああ
これはでも広くてがあたりだと思いませんでドラゴン part の有名なアニメや
その竜眼前に出てくる貯蔵四球あの
みんながよく知ってるゴキブリの方が当たりましたね
ヒモ者いっぱいを黒いやつおっぱ持ってクラウド a かわいい代わりなんかねこの
よく見たことあるぜスパーきっていうおいなちゃんですねえ普通に可愛いや何これこの
人の中の友達ですね
シュッっ
ポンザケンナーでこれをさあ
反対になりましたホイノボリ少ないですよはいデザー
さっきの公有地パティスターのメンバーです
はぁっはぁっはぁったぶんこんな匂いが好きな事柄とすごい嬉しいんですよ
なんか何もわかんないんで酒んだって感じですねてあべりょうイラストで最後に何か
こう飛び抜けて嬉しいのが出てきたらすごい嬉しいと思っていますドイツみなさんこれ
アレですからね
一方
他では見れない情報ですからかなりすごい動画ですよ
それをできたって本当に僕は生きてて幸せでしたねえとーございましてやてぃブーバー
球を超えたスパーキーダーって保ってますね
魂のとリア4パティスパティと魚って
名古屋きゅるんですんだろう時んだかってことのほうの金玉でしたありがとうござい
ました
[音楽]
me
バッハ